now today for our daily cancellation we
must discuss the huge
massive important scandal surrounding a
recent wall street journal op-ed
uh that op-ed if you could believe it if
you can even stomach hearing about it if
you can endure the shock that op-ed
criticized
jill biden shocking stuff yes the big
news here is that
first ladies are off limits again after
four years of melania trump being mocked
and belittled and criticized ruthlessly
even having her you know private
conversations secretly recorded and
published
i can now report that it is once again
sexist to say anything bad about the
first lady
the ring of protection is being placed
around her
once more that this ring of protection
only seems to descend from the heavens
when there's a democrat in the white
house is of course entirely coincidental
whether it'll be sexist or not to
criticize the first lady that is
something decided
by the alignment of the planets and the
stars it's quite mystical and mysterious
there is nothing political about it
trust me on this
and that is why this editorial from a
man named joseph epstein
has been met with extraordinary
unquenchable rage
here's the report in variety about it it
says the wall street journal is facing
backlash to its december 11th op-ed that
chided
incoming first lady lady dr jill biden
and suggested that she drop
the doctor from her title during her
time in the white house written by
joseph epstein the column states that dr
jill biden
that quote dr jill biden sounds and
feels fraudulent
not to say a touch comic contending that
because biden has her doctorate in
education
not medicine she should drop the title
the piece also calls biden
a quote kiddo sorry excuse me i'm
i'm so scandalized that she called that
he called her kiddo that i have to stop
and collect myself for a moment
that's rough stuff that is rough rough
stuff
kiddo my god that piece also just
suggests that that someone should only
be called doctor
if they have delivered a child and
undermines the value of her education
but many people on twitter felt
differently and didn't hold back in
expressing their opinions
jill biden's spokesman michael larosa
blasted the essays sentiments
and the journal's decision to run it
addressing the wall street journal's
editorial features editor
larosa wrote on twitter james toronto
you in the wall street journal should be
embarrassed to print the disgusting and
sexist attack on dr biden running on the
opinion page if you had any respect for
women at all you would remove this
repugnant display of chauvinism from
your paper
and apologize to her hillary clinton
tweeted a simple yet effective statement
her name is dr jill biden get used to it
will and grace actor deborah messing
told the wall street journal that their
hatred for women is showing
and called the whole ordeal a disgusting
display of misogyny
jamal bowman the democratic
representative elect for new york's 16th
congressional district
and former middle school principal wrote
that quote the erasure of dr jill
biden's expertise is shrouded in both
sexism and disrespect for the teaching
profession
educators are experts he continued while
we're at it it's also
dr jamal bowman um
and on and on lots of histrionics lots
of tearful sexism accusations lots of
academics without medical degrees
touting their own credentials
jill biden excuse me dr jill biden did
not address the controversy directly but
did offer this response on twitter which
is being hailed as an epic clapback
she said together we will build a world
where the accomplishments of our
daughters will be celebrated
rather than diminished and to that i
would say yes
we should celebrate our daughter's
accomplishments we should also celebrate
jill biden's accomplishments
as soon as she has one for now i must
admit i tend to agree
with joseph epstein jill biden got a
doctor in education at the age of 55.
so good for her but i'm just not
terribly impressed by a rich woman with
lots of time on her hands and no young
kids to care for
getting a doctorate in education i
certainly don't see why
i should have to acknowledge the
achievement every time i say her name
you know you could say it takes a lot of
work to get a doctor in education
i'm skeptical but maybe that's true what
i do know though is that it takes a lot
of work to become a great mechanic
or an expert electrician there are
carpenters with so much skill and
experience that they have reached the
level of master carpenter
and yet if i was a master carpenter and
insisted that you address me as
master walsh you'd think i was insane
and that's exactly how i feel about
people without medical degrees
going around calling themselves doctors
and demanding that you address them
accordingly in fact
even medical doctors shouldn't want you
to call them doctor outside of the
doctor's office or professional
you know similar professional setting i
can see the need to single out
the doctors with a special title when
you're actually in a medical environment
it's important to acknowledge who's the
doctor who isn't right i don't see any
reason to treat doctors with greater
reverence or courtesy
than i would anyone else in general
society though
so even a medical doctor is only mr or
mrs to me when i see them on the street
but somebody with a doctorate in
education why would i give
any special notice to that whatsoever
i could sooner be convinced to honor a
you know to to honor someone with a
title
uh if they're you know a long tenured
shift supervisor at wendy's
as i find his achievements far more
impressive than earning a useless
degree because you're in your 50s and
looking for something to do in fact
given that the fast food industry has
been deemed essential by the government
maybe all the people in that line of
work can affix essential to their names
as a permanent honorific actually
media is essential too apparently so i
can do the same
my name is lord matt walsh essential
pleased to meet you
or it would be i guess just lord walsh
es in writing
the lord part i'm just throwing in there
because why not you know i mean we could
just add whatever titles we want i guess
i could go buy a plot of land in
scotland or something and officially
earn the title i suppose
in the end of course it doesn't matter
what jill biden calls herself
it's just sort of annoying and
pretentious the main thing that
makes me want to defend epstein is that
all of the most
irritating and absurd people are losing
their minds over what he said
the more they demand that we call jill
biden doctor and cry that it's sexist if
we don't
the more i must insist otherwise and
laugh
at their tears or bottle them in
the handy vessel i have here for such
purposes and that's why all the people
whining today
are dr jill biden is also canceled
so says i dr lord sir mr walsh esquire
iv
also by the way uh ben shapiro is going
to have more a lot more to say
on uh on this subject and his wife is a
doctor by the way if you hadn't heard so
i'll be interested to hear his take on
on this issue but
in any case jill biden is still
cancelled
i'm afraid hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated